good evening Thank you very much for
calling vi Buenos
Aires cash only sir we accept
euros and dollars big face it's not the pcol face
[Music]
capito a little bit of
tent Tom Dale perfect I found out that
your building was destroyed a new figurine you
don't have a foundation  supportive the
foundation
helping I have never liked the
people who work to be good they are
the worst gab surprising is the value of
the
expenses is frada with
slabs I brought him a pancake for my
birthday I asked for
that on top of it I spent it after what
you did to me if you remember me  return the
taer if you don't remember everything is fine
Goodbye do you really think you have the power
to extort me B
here I know perfectly well that you are a
dark and
dangerous guy
with children
[Music]
from
ah